if i'm choosing to dress the way i dress
and that does not hurt anyone else i
don't think i'm going to go to hell for
[Music]
it
for a woman the hijab just pretty much
stands for being modest
with your appearance and letting people
see you for
who you are your personality and not
just your looks
when people think about hijab they think
of a piece of cloth
but to me it's like my identity i just
haven't worn it yet because i don't
think i've found a connection with it i
took off my job probably
almost a year ago when i decided to take
it off i kind of escaped from the muslim
community a little bit
some of us are upbringings our mosques
made us have difficult relationships
with hijab that's something that i had
i do think that there are certain groups
that wear the hijab that think
that if you don't wear it that you don't
connect with islam a lot of
hijabis would pick on people who are not
hijabis they think that we're lesser
than a reader not as
religious or we're not praying five
times a day like no we're doing that too
can we be equal and not judge
so much
[Music]
my name is fatima i am a student at ucla
studying anthropology and film i'm shaam
i'm also a student at ucla but i'm
studying international development
my name is jenna and i also am a pre-med
biology student
and i work in a medical field too i'm
saba or saba
depends on how you want to say it i'm a
senior in high school
i'm lean and i'm a business analyst for
a healthcare company
i'm marwa or marwa and i do a lot of
journalism and fundraising and really
random things on social media
i want you to step forward and take a
seat if you agree
so the first prompt is a hijabi woman
is a better muslim
oh
i'm shocked i'm sitting here when we
read the quote on we get our own
interpretations of it but it does say
that
in there to only show your hands face
and feet
if god says it then i definitely think
that is better
but i don't think the behavior of acting
like you're better than someone that i
don't
see that's right
i actually have so much to say about
this so far it's dark
okay i think a lot of people think that
it's like a point system
oh yes hijab ding you know like next
level and i don't think
god is like this person wears the hijab
you're good to go
versus this person doesn't so and you're
out i think everything else that you do
weighs in i do know many hijabis that
like do not follow anything else
and i know a lot of non-hijabis that are
the most religious you know women that
i've ever met i have a friend on like
instagram who dresses however she wants
to dress
and she could rock it she has a body for
it but she goes to every friday prayer
and i'm like
she's a better person and i do find that
like
when it comes to behavior on the muslim
community i find that ritual takes
precedent over behavior a lot of the
times to the point where like
people are just outright mean to each
other but they don't realize that that's
a sin too you know
and when people say you're doing this
wrong it kind of like does deter your
relationship a little bit you know
you you second guess even your
relationship with allah which should be
there should be no complications it
should just be pure there's so many
things that are disregarded essence
because they don't seem like even like
with interest or whatever they're like
it's technically a thing that people
just overlook when it comes to hijab
that's like
everyone's main focus the scrutiny
behind it is like insane
i think the muslims create chaos around
it
because they want to feel like they're
the right ones doing it
the right way but to your point like
you're if you're talking let's talk
about hijab for example
you don't do that do you yeah i'm
sitting right now i'm i know that
if you have to say well i'm more
rebellious you know you're doing
something wrong and that's
shaytan trying to get you to normalize
it a lot of sins that we're doing
we're being normalized we're in america
is the most sinful country probably ever
i so disagree with you about something i
disagree about making excuses
i'm not saying that this thing is okay
and like in america it's all right
actually god didn't say it no but i am
saying i don't think i'm going to go to
hell for it
i am saying i'm aware that i'm acting
like this
but i just don't think of god as a
punisher because i think that affects my
relationship with him
i think of him as a very like loving
kind of like don't do this because i
want to protect you
but i get why you have the temptation to
do it so do you think people are going
to hell if you don't think he's a
punisher
i think if your actions affect
other people personally you are going to
hell and i know this can be nitpicked
because like a man can look at you i
understand that but
you know if i'm choosing to dress the
way i dress and that technically like
does not hurt anyone else you know it's
just
my personal choice i don't think you're
going to hell i think it's such a
personal relationship between me and
you know god although you know that kind
of thing it frustrates me when people
get involved because i'm like it's none
of your business
right let me do me you know
i have not worn a hijab i do think it's
like a very
loud image of islam i think it's a very
clear representation of it
it can be terrifying because it's like
you're a walking symbol at all times
but i also think it's a very clear
symbol of strength i think it takes a
lot of strength to wear it
i don't know if i personally have that
strength as of right now
the hijab was created to protect women
that's what they said in the quran it
said only show your hands
feet and face and it's supposed to
protect you from the opposite sex
yeah no just like reflecting back not
just like wearing it as a head scarf but
like wearing long sleeves and like just
dressing more modestly in general
i've like protected me from a lot i
think it is like a two-way street i
think you know there are a lot of things
mentioned for the other sex lower your
gaze and all that
but i do think it was meant as a
protective measure in a certain
way i do believe that the hijab does
provide protection in some
ways but i don't think it was created
for the purpose
of protection so like if you had to say
it was created
for something would you say it's more of
a modesty thing or what
to you what do you think it really
represents then well i think that hijab
is so
complicated he also uses the word which
literally translates to headscarf this
isn't called the hijab this is called
is the actual translation for the head
covering that covers your chest
and there's a lot of translations that
came in that have called this a scarf
and that's where the confusion has set
in and so they're like well it doesn't
have to cover it's just a veil or it's
just a piece of cloth
well i think of the hijab i think a bit
more like the principle behind it
modesty and humility
and just like not being too outlandish
and so i don't think it's super gendered
i feel like the hijab is something that
men in their way should be also
observing
yeah no that that's definitely true a
dude should not be checking me out like
i think the hijab like prevents that
like for example without my hijab i go
to like a solid like eight out of ten
appearance like attraction-wise
and with the hijab i'm like you know a
two and i think it does a really good
job like when it makes me uglier i feel
like
good job hijab you know i think we
should just preface it like islam isn't
the one dictating all this it's
literally like muslim culture
exactly exactly like the way you wear
hijab like for example the way that i'm
wearing it right now is like a no-no to
many people yeah
like they're like oh my god like you
know that little chin is showing i don't
know
like i can't wear pants yeah yeah
yeah by my sister actually i wore it up
in a bun
like combined to then she actually was
talking behind my back in a muslim
community talking like oh she's crazy
she's a [ __ ] and i'm like
but you have stories too like i don't
get it
women are headed to higher standards of
modesty than men
can i run where do i start
where do i start can we talk about how
guys can like go out
clubbing drinking but go out and have
girlfriends and that's totally fine
don't even that's an eye when it comes
to girls in the same thing it's like oh
they need to experience life yeah
they're going to experience like kids
they have to get it out of their system
before they get married yeah yeah no one
is like oh don't
marry that guy because oh my god
yeah a girl gets caught at the mall
having a conversation with a
store associate and then someone's mom
sees that girl and she's like
nobody marry that woman's daughter she
saw her at the mall with a boy i just
want to say i've never gone to a guy's
photo and looked at the comments no
one's calling him a [ __ ]
or a [ __ ] or you're going to hell for
what you're wearing
or your your ankles are showing just the
basic line of like
clothing we experience so
much more i want to know what they think
i know i'm so curious
oh yeah i disagree completely because
it's more of a cultural thing i think i
took the prompt very
literally and applied to islam i don't
think islam necessarily lets
guys get away with more i mean at the
end of the day like if they're gonna go
out like if they're gonna go live their
best life
let them allah is the final judge it's
none of my business i'm gonna stay out
of it and i think it's more cultural
than
religious right so that's why i 100
degree but if it's cultural i'll be here
all day long i i agree with you i don't
think it's religious at all i was
thinking culture oh i was thinking of
purely religious i think that throughout
history it's a patriarchal history
there are parts of the religion itself
that are
different for men and women in a way
that it seems like
it's because the men are the ones who
are saying these things people say look
there's no female prophets i'm not sure
about that
i don't know there could have been
female prophets and just never had their
stories told the understanding of
religion that we have
as humans is purely based on the fact
that humans are the ones telling us
these stories about religion
i would say that i've seen a lot of like
gender things very gendered to the point
that we don't even explore people who
are not fixed in those binaries you know
we don't talk about queer muslims we
don't talk about anything like that
i feel like there's just like people
just too afraid to talk about that
because their afraid is going to be
questioning the religion
before 2016 i never thought i would be
wearing hijab anytime soon in my mind i
was like oh
get married i'll have kids and then like
some point in my life i'll throw it on
and i think
i was being guided in a wrong way when
it came to the conversation around hijab
wearing hijab is a promise between you
and god
a more difficult level of faith
but the struggle is part of the devotion
i think personally it depends i know
some like christian women argue that the
hijab is technically instilled in the
bible and that they want to wear it and
i feel like in that case
it's totally okay when it comes to like
fashion purposes or just wearing it just
for the look i feel like in that case i
would disagree
well i think that's actually awesome if
a non-muslim tries to wear hijab
and they try to cover or be modest i
think that's amazing because it is
considered a good deed and
if that's what you want to do and it
maybe leads you into islam alhamdulillah
you know you're better than me right now
so good job
i think i was looking at it more like um
if i had a let's say a non-muslim friend
that wanted to come with me
to let's say the mosque and they put it
on i think that's acceptable
yeah it's to be respectful yes exactly
i actually took this as more of a
cultural appreciation versus
appropriation type of topic i think we
can all agree we're going to define
hijab
as a lifestyle and cultural everything
wise
type of statement so i took it as that
and like i think someone brought up the
friend coming to the message that's
appreciation yeah
not appropriation like like netflix
shows they have a hijabi take it off
no babe i have such an issue with that
because
like again it goes back to this whole
idea of like we have no freedom we are
in this closet 24 7. we're in a bubble
we live on i know
no no no just because you like a boy
you're not going to take off your hijab
for him
every hijabi
come on dude we are so much more than
the girl who's
trapped inside of her house she's like
screw my religion
muslim women are like misrepresented all
the time there was a thing with rihanna
where she just put it on for a photo
that is something that frustrates me i
didn't have a problem with that really
we do that like we come on muslim women
do that why can't rihanna do it
that's appreciation to me she's wearing
it out of respect for being out of my
[ __ ] and she's
not her job he's do that yeah we do that
like i put scarfs on
when i want to i pose for it when i want
to
sometimes i do it because i'm around
hijabis when i want to well i was just
going to say it's just because they have
such a privilege where they can take it
off whenever wow
i just remember the greatest example of
all time because okay so mia khalifa
that one video
of her i don't like obvi like you know
from that i get called mia khalifa all
the time i can't believe that i don't
want to do it
and i don't like that it goes back to
the whole fetishizing thing and i think
it's
been like oh are you on some like mia
khalifa type i'm like
no no miya khalifa did it so you can't
no
no no no like this this this this
goodness
is not for anyone to see it's for it's
for the person that'll love me
it'll it's for the person that will
respect me it's for the person that i
will have kids with insha allah
that's what it's for it's not for any of
y'all
uh the boston bombing had just happened
and
uh i was really young i was supposed to
go
to a field trip to a mosque and i
remember that people
started growling outside my school
because i went to an islamic school and
i just saw all the hate
and i realized that that's not what
islam is and i need to represent it and
the first thing that i could do to
represent it
is start by wearing my hijab i have been
harassed
for wearing a hijab
there's just been so many cases at
school i've had multiple times where
people would you know come from the back
and be like boot and then take off my
scarf pull it off that's like taking up
a person's clothing
exactly the way that i feel naked
without it like i felt so
ashamed and i think that's just not
right especially because i had to go to
such a young age
but uh i i wish that there are so many
advantages of being a non-hijabi than
being a hijabi
tsa airports oh yeah i'm just in the
other girl what about the hand stuff
do the hand stuff you go through the
thing and they're like can you see your
hands and they put it on them like oh
what is this for they're like we're
looking for bomb residue and i'm like
yeah
they've said that that's you yeah
and um the red city i live in they're
not openly racist
they're kindly racist oh my gosh this
woman i encountered at the grocery store
i was reaching for milk she's like
sweetie
you live in america now you don't have
to wear that yeah she thought she was
doing me a favor that's the weird thing
disappearing
the superiority it was the white savior
thing yeah
hearing your guys's stories i feel like
it like hurts a little because i've
heard
them so many times it's always the same
like
go back to your country this is america
i've never worn the hijab
so i can never say i know the experience
but i have seen it
does it discourage you like our stories
at all for you to like
be scared to like try it on or um no i
don't want fear to control me
the reason i don't wear it is just more
personal reasons i guess
more than it is the society's effect on
me you know
i have to be honest like i experienced
privilege not wearing hijab people don't
see me as muslim first and i've lived my
whole life being seen as muslim first so
when people say like why would you take
it off or whatever sometimes like it
happens whereas like you're tired of all
of that and you want to like
not be identified or you whatever hijab
is definitely a struggle
and a lot of hijabis struggle with hijab
every day and then we got the hate from
the right wing we got the hate from
inside the muslim community even yeah
the super progressive left feminist
not just all feminists but like you know
the exact ones i'm talking about and
then we have
every single other kind of person
on the outside like take it off and
you're like
i want to you know but i'm not going to
because
because for me it's like if i take it
off what am i really looking for
i'm looking for a convenience but i
shouldn't care about those things when i
die none of that will matter
like going to your point when i work job
like i actually liked
me wearing as like a you know few to
like western beauty standards to like
all of that
and so when i was thinking about like
whether i wanted to wear it or not i was
like
i'm going to be kind of like giving in
to the you know
what people see as like beautiful or
what people see as like
normal or whatever but um i guess for me
it was becoming harder for me to
to understand like my purpose between
wearing the hijab because i never got
the ability to choose to wear it my
parents just put it on me
so i think for myself like i'm taking a
break the one thing that you were saying
about like you know your parents put you
in it i'm so sorry that happened because
that discourages so many people to wear
it and that is not right because i am my
own individual and that's what the hijab
allowed me to do like i think what it
did for you is the exact opposite
case right because i got that choice but
i hope you stay on to your faith and i
hope you stay on tier
stay strong straight down ladies
[Music]
there's a lot of pressure to wear from
people and
there's a lack of an informed decision
based on your own ideals i just
wanted to get a clean state and find out
for myself if it was my choice because i
didn't get that opportunity
i don't think there could be a time
where i could ever remove the hijab i'm
in a really comfortable place with it
now i always want to normalize
just muslim women in general because
there's always like a negative stigma
towards muslim women that wear hijab
especially
it's really frustrating that i hear that
we're oppressed
so it's really important for me to wear
it and
show people that we are normal people
we're just like regular girls we just
happen to wear it for our religion
modesty in islam should be redefined for
the 21st century
oh ah don't know thank you
[Laughter]
it has to do with lifestyle choices and
things like that so for example like
women didn't start working until when
not very long ago yeah a couple of
decades ago life was very different than
culturally speaking we should change but
religiously speaking how come how much
can you really change like islam gives
women so much it allows us to
be whoever we want act however we want
do whatever we want and keep our income
and stuff like that
modesty is just a really broad term i
totally understand where you're coming
from but i definitely think that
um staying stuck in the same mindset can
be very damaging
you know i can't be like it was done
like this so we have to keep doing it
like this
and i also think it changes from country
to country so like i personally lived in
syria for seven years
and the things that i can get away with
here are not the same things that i can
get away with there
and so what they consider modest is
different than what we consider
yeah i think
that the human in us the sinners in us
wants it to change so we can do more i
think low-key
we all want to address a certain way so
we can be attractive
and how you want to present yourself to
be attractive is
sexual attraction from the opposite sex
if you want that
that's fine but i think that's what it
is loki i feel like a lot of islamic
scholars sort of just try to relate it
to
this generation i think people just try
to make it easier based off of how other
people are dressed here yeah
but it's still super clear and i don't
think it should be like altered based
off of
the year we're living in i would say i
don't think it's super clear even within
the quran there's so many
interpretations of every single text
so we don't know exactly what allah
meant when i said cover this in that
because people had interpreted crazy
different ways
we should move the conversation away
from specific physical clothing
acts and rituals and focus on the
lifestyle i think we should focus on
both
i think yeah but why do you want it to
change off of i don't think we need to
redefine modesty because i think that
modesty in itself is not a dated or
archaic kind of like concept
i think modesty is like the holistic
way that we treat each other and
obviously like the different acts that
we do to portray modesty
has differed but i would say modesty as
a whole is like
same from the beginning of islam or to
now
alhamdulillah we did it
yes
you